[Music]
creativity it's at the heart of who we
humans are with brains equipped by
evolution to invent to write to make art
and music
we humans are special right but wait
what if a robot could paint a
masterpiece
what if artificial intelligence could
compose great music does a robot a
machine with artificial intelligence
driven by code and algorithms feel and
express itself uniquely and originally
you are just a machine an imitation of
life can a robot write a symphony can a
robot turn a canvas into a beautiful
masterpiece can you
over some 40,000 years human creativity
has exploded from drawings on cave walls
through the great art of centuries to
come to ever more advanced technology
and design
[Music]
now scientists and artists are asking
can a robot truly imagine an original
master work or can it only copy the
patterns of a human painter or musician
does this computer version of Ivaldi
sound like the real thing can artificial
intelligence feel emotion and turn it
into art do algorithms with yes/no
options have the potential for unlimited
creativity even the human brain with its
86 billion neurons may have creative
limits computational creativity is
leading us to ask new questions about
human creativity is this essential human
trait truly unique
how far can it take us will artificial
intelligence be a competitor or can it
be a collaborator helping us toward
still
[Music]
and welcome to computational creativity
my first guest is a member of Google
brains magenta team he is currently
working on neural network models of
sound and music and recently produced a
synthesizer that designs its own sounds
it's also a jazz guitarist
please welcome Jesse angle also with us
is an assistant professor at the
University of Illinois at
urbana-champaign in the Department of
Electrical and Computer Engineering he
focuses on several surprising creative
domains including the keulen Airy Arts
in fashion and the theoretical
foundations of creativity please welcome
live Varshney
also with us is an associate professor
of psychological and brain sciences at
Dartmouth College he is interested in
the neural basis of imagination and in
the evolution of human creativity please
welcome Peter C and finally an artist in
residence at Bell Labs exploring new
forms of drawing with virtual reality
biometrics machine learning and robotics
a former research fellow at MIT 's Media
Lab and artist in residence at Google
please welcome sequential it seems like
you know there there are many possible
pros and cons for approaching
computational creativity
one potential con would be we don't even
fully understand human creativity yet I
mean as someone who has studied the
evolution of you human creativity where
does it come from what do we know about
it what don't we know about it mammals
that have descended from a very long
lineage and in the hominin lineage we
diverged from chimpanzee at something
like seven million years ago or from the
common ancestor with chimpanzees and
bonobos about seven million years ago
and we went through a long period of
having small brains we were bipedal the
Australopithecus means what you can see
in the lower left there and in the lower
middle but then around 2.2 million years
ago Homo habilis created stone tools and
these old device stone tools were very
simple basically just broken rocks but
then about 1.8 million years ago two
point 2.0 million years ago Homo erectus
in the upper middle there created a kind
of hand axe called the Chilean hand axe
which hardly changed for a million and a
half years so it's really striking is
how an innovative Homo erectus was
and yeah yeah we're done a good idea
yeah you know and then you know the
heidelbergensis which is in the upper
right there is about six hundred eight
hundred thousand years ago again very
non innovative and even the Neanderthals
who had this so-called mysterion tool
set had it hardly changed for over one
hundred and fifty thousand years and
then our species shows up and in the
case of Europe kind of in the middle of
you are probably became up the Danube
and could go any further and show and
their artifacts are incredible right you
see the first evidence of instruments of
art and we can't know for sure how this
came about because soft only fossils
neural circuits only fossils all we have
our bones and skulls and artifacts but
the artifacts that show up are just
incredible right stone flute I mean I'm
bone flutes and beautiful art so
something happened in our neural
circuitry that afforded us the capacity
to think of such things and then paint
them or create them and some of them
involve the creation of objects that
existed in their world like that bison
up there but some of them involve the
creation of objects that could not exist
and near own in what is now Germany
there's a cave where they found this
Leuven mensch this lion headed human so
there was never a lion headed humans so
somebody had to imagine that thirty five
to forty thousand years ago and then go
and build it though I'm very interested
in the neural circuitry that could have
created that so just just to be clear
this is not a result of some kind of
physical evolution the brainpan doesn't
get we don't see a an increase in size
of the the brain and the species no we
do see an increase in the size of the
brain from roughly the size of a
chimpanzee 350 cubic centimeters up
through Homo habilis getting up to maybe
600
see see Homo erectus gets bigger bigger
and bigger and what and the Neanderthals
actually had brains that were bigger
than ours much bigger well not much
bigger made 1400 1450 CC whereas ours is
about 1,300 and yet Neanderthals were
there bigger brains were not very
innovative their tools hardly changed
but what really seems to change in our
skulls and in our brains because the
skull molds to fit the brain is this our
foreheads got really big so something
about our frontal cortex changed and I
suspect this was very central to our
becoming more creative so when did this
happen I mean Homo sapiens as a species
was around for a while and it seems like
what you're saying I mean it sort of
describes a j-curve you know where
there's an explosion of vintage puzzle
right so I can look at a skull from
130,000 years ago and it looks more or
less like a modern a modern skull but
the first evidence of sort of jewelry
and art is maybe 70 maybe 80 thousand
years ago in South Africa and the Blum
Bose cave and in Europe cro-magnon man
our our species shows up about 41,000
years ago give or take a couple thousand
years and it really seemed to be a big
bang a cultural big bang and what that
was I think nobody knows was it a change
in culture a change in language nobody
knows but laughs I mean you've studied
some of the theoretical foundations of
creativity it is important to at least
ask these questions because if we're
going to talk about computational
creativity we need to know what we're
starting from exactly and so what I've
been working on is a mathematical theory
of creativity which again seems perhaps
strange right how can you mathematize
something like my creativity and the way
I've been defining it is we want things
that are both novel as well as
high-quality in the domain so if we're
thinking about food we want it to be
flavorful or if we want fashion we want
it to be visually appealing
perhaps but novelty seems to be fairly
consistent across domains things that
change your beliefs are perhaps the most
surprising and the most known
the human brain as neuroscientists know
is it has very finely balanced between
the need for knowing what's coming next
expectation the satisfaction the brain
gets when it knows the next digit in the
sequence or the next word in the
sentence versus novelty and you know
whether you can mathematically determine
that sweet spot is is still kind of an
open question I would imagine it is yeah
how to balance novelty against
familiarity that's that's really the
question but artist is you don't want to
deviate too much perhaps because then
it's uh not understandable that you
definitely want to push the envelope so
with food I mean does the computer put
together things that no human chef would
ever dream of putting together like yeah
like blueberries and pork and yeah you
can definitely come up with novel
combinations that have never been done
before so things like cocoa powder
saffron and almonds for example that's
incredibly good but you've also been
working with an algorithm that you know
if you go if we're going to talk about
the artificial intelligence learning you
know they're they're the different
algorithms that enable it to do that so
before we get to Jesse and his musical
tools talk us through this algorithm
that helps to learn a machine to learn
to create music right so what we wanted
to do is essentially learn what are the
laws of music theory what are the
principles of good music as it were
[Music]
was doing is the past two hearts
essentially a teacher that knows both
and a student who is trying to learn
what what is music and they iterate
between each other so we want to build
this hierarchy of concepts and music and
further we want them to be human
interpretable and so that's roughly what
this algorithm tries to do and then
eventually we can use those principles
than to inform composition the
generative question of both creativity
so is there an analogy to how we as
humans would learn the theory of making
music algorithm generates are exactly or
nearly the ones that they're taught in
music theory courses they go step by
step in in roughly the same way though
there are a couple of rules that come
come out that some of our colleagues and
in colleges of music find kind of
interesting as well things that they
hadn't noticed that Jesse in the field
of music we have seen some attempts made
at quote-unquote generated music Brian
Eno for example in England has been
pursuing this for years what what is the
attraction in taking something that
seems to be so inherently human and and
trying to expand that into the world of
artificial intelligence that's a great
question so I think it's interesting to
think of things in the context that
creativity and tools have always been Co
evolving right we weren't able to you
know the evolution of well tempered
instruments allowed for you know playing
in multiple keys and algorithms and
machine learning artificial intelligence
are just sort of the next step in this
process where they're creating new
opportunities to interact with
composition new interactivity new ways
to interact with sonic texture and and
just new tools to express ourselves
creativity what what are you and the
magenta team at Google what is your kind
of approach to the music creativity
process what's interesting about machine
learning and you know what's called AI
is that it's really a data-driven way or
at least a lot of the current methods
are a data-driven way
of discovering some of these core
components to a given set of data
whether it be you know audio from
someone talking or you know the core
components of a recipe or anything like
that and so once you've identified these
core components then you can start
playing games about like well how do we
mix and match them the systems aren't
perfect you know they fail in
interesting ways because they're trying
to do the best they can and they're
trying to do according to the data that
we show them and the data we show them
comes from the natural world so the
mistakes they make are somewhat in line
with the natural world and so they have
a kind of more humanistic character to
them which is actually a great source of
it's a different type of creativity this
is a you know creativity through trial
and error you know or mistake
that sounds very human I mean right you
know Jamaican musicians in the early 60s
listening to offshore radio from the
southern American states and thinking oh
I got to do me some of that R&B stuff
and getting it wrong and creating reggae
you know I mean this is right this is
how almost every kind of development in
in our arts has happened or like in the
case of the the 808 drum machine was
originally invented to be a perfectly
accurate drummer it was supposed to be a
replacement of a drummer but it wasn't
that sounds like a drum in a box you
know but it actually the way that it was
not perfect that the kick drum and stuff
was actually you know the starting point
for a lot of electronic music and
hip-hop and you know that so there's
there's the way that you have your
creative intention and then it goes a
little bit off but if you're guiding
your creative intention if it's grounded
in the world it can be a great creative
sources you know with these machines is
the learning experiential can it be
experiential or is it completely based
on what we the people have have taught
it no I definitely think it can be
experienced the the standard way of
teaching things is to give it a bunch of
exemplars you know and then it has to
try to
I mean it meaning the algorithm that you
come up with has to try to determine
some structure within that but there's
an alternative way where you give a
bunch of core components you know and an
algorithm can try to combine these
components in different ways and there's
evolutionary algorithms which sort of
like you sort of take these two things
and they say like well what if I combine
them I would have to a you know a child
of them and there's also reinforcement
learning where you sort of give it
feedback if it combined two things in a
good way then you say okay good job you
know and it does more things like that
and those are some of the frontiers of
these types of algorithms all right now
at the table there you have a kind of
melody generating system that what's
this theory into practice yeah so the
Google magenta project it's part of a
machine learning machine learning
research group so we do fundamental
research but one of the key things I
think often gets overlooked is there's
always a human in the creative process
and so we're really it's an open source
project that we try to get as much
engagement from creative coders and
artists in the community and we try to
create tools that allow these artists to
interact with these algorithms and
without having to you know do a bunch of
programming on the command line and that
type of stuff so I just brought along a
kind of them here to show well why don't
you you know demonstrate what this thing
can do sue Gwen while while Jesse's
walking over to the table does this this
is you know sound analogous to to your
sort of collaboration I started a
robotic drawing collaboration a few
years ago with the intent of exploring
what how we could measure creativity and
actually reflect that back as as a type
of performance so I think as I've come
to work with the robotic arm and with
these new machine learning algorithms
I've come to view it as more of a
collaborator because of its ability to
reflect our own creative processes and I
think that's a new process that's only
going to grow more in the future what
are we looking at
so this is
my project drawing operations unit
generation one it's sort of a first very
initial foray into what it would be like
to collaborate with a robotic agent the
the first generation is really simple I
wanted to show a few things I wanted to
show sort of a human hand and a robotic
arm working in harmony because I feel
like that image is really and that
narrative is under under served in in
our culture now and also think about how
relationally and how behaviorally the
sort of to organic and robotic units
could work together to create something
beautiful or not and kind of explore
that sight of ambiguity and Jesse was
talking about yeah I think you were
saying that you know for you getting the
feedback from the Machine you know
affects your creative process so it
becomes a feedback loop absolutely yeah
you did bring one other video for us to
watch what's happening here oh this is
just sort of an older installation work
of mine I think it hits upon this sort
of unique point in history that we're in
where a lot of how we work with
traditional mediums and how we engage in
music and and food how that's being
shifted and transmuted by these
different technological systems so this
is an installation project that I did a
few years ago which combines sort of
handmade paper crafts with computational
graphics to create an environment that's
sort of this union of both so it is a
genuine collaborative process it's it's
a it's a hybrid process yeah let's take
a look
[Music]
[Music]
so the idea that it's a hybrid process
it seemed like maybe you were hedging on
whether it was a genuine collaboration
yet is that is that the goal I think
that's that's definitely the goal for me
I'd like to see more people engage with
you know the the machine learning
behaviors as part of a process that they
adopt into their own work it's I think
we're always inching closer and closer
towards true collaboration even with
human actors so there's a there's a real
area to be explored there all right so
what do you got over there
okay so what I have here is a
demonstration of a very common type of
model and machine learning where there's
given a series of notes it looks for
structure within those notes and tries
to keep on continuing and predicting
what would what would I play next if I
was the one that had played those notes
and so there's a lot of different ways
that you can use that within a creative
process and so we've taken tens of
thousands of popular songs and just the
notes from this song so it's called MIDI
data but we train these models to find
the structure there and then to be able
to generate new sounds when conditioned
on you know when listening to what it is
that someone's playing so if sound works
out here just to just to keep me at all
centered I'm gonna put a metronome on
but I could do something where I might
have a melody that I'm gonna play into
and you'll hear the electric piano will
be me
and then I'm gonna hear a response from
the algorithm running on my computer
here that will be trying to continue
when I'm what I'm playing it'll be a
cello so I might go something simple
might respond so there's some continuity
there with what I played before I have
it looping actually but you can hear
them so you can hear the response over
and over again you can see here's some
similarity to what I play but it's not
it's not doing the job of trying to
replicate what I played it's trying to
continue it in a meaningful way it's
done a little inversion of some of the
you know a little version but you see
sort of keeping for the same key and
stuff so if I then wanted to go and like
play chords behind it you know it's sort
of like say oh that sounds really good
as like a melody for my song maybe I
could build off that and be like
you know or something like that and all
of a sudden I got the start of of course
a very popular hit but that's that's
just sort of one type of one type of way
that you can you know be using these
tools well and another type of way is
the sounds themselves right I mean we we
know what instruments sound like right
because we've made all of them right
right but there are potentially a
gazillion other sounds out there so we
have to take a whole bunch of individual
instruments and we haven't learned the
structure between all those different
instruments and then provide that as a
tool to a musician so that you can
interpolate between different
instruments and create sounds that are
sort of novel and new and yes was
there's a similar idea but applied anout
to tambour and texture so like in this
example we could take the sound
originally of a flute sounds like a
flute and so here's the models best
attempt to to replicate that sound you
notice it it sounds more or less like a
flute but it you know it Mick it messes
up in some ways that there's this upper
high frequency content stuff but it's
it's actually like I was saying those
are kind of mistakes that we enjoy you
know that it it's sort of like you're
running back in the old days you know
the sixties people would would run there
turn up their tube amplifiers and get
this upper harmonic distortion and so
it's sort of its natural type of
distortion but you could take on the
other side and you know for novelty sake
let's say let's take a cat so my wife
loves cats so she was like you have to
do a cat you have to do a cat
so here's the model there was only
trained on instruments like guitars and
flutes this is its best attempt to
recreate a cat sounds like a cat but
it's like if the cat was played by
things so if you take the flute and the
cat if you were just to add the numbers
corresponding to those waves together it
would just sound like the cat and the
flute in the same room you know there's
two separate sound sources but instead
if we take those core components
the network learns and we mix those core
components together then we get
something that's a new sound that
combines elements of the two sounds
together so it sort of sounds like a
flute that meows and I can then turn
that into an instrument that I can play
and of course you know it's very fun and
novelty you know all good but we also
want to encourage more than just novelty
you know the creation of new not serious
but you know a personal expression so
we've also created these tools in the
integrate that integrated them into
modern musical workflows as well is
there anything similar to that in yeah
so once you have these components you
can start playing around with them even
in other domains like say culinary right
you can say I want a gin flavored
ceviche using dairy products right so
and you can you'll have an algorithm
that will generate something that's
pretty flavorful and pretty good so you
can set up and once I think this is
probably true for you to Jesse as well
once you start using these things you
kind of get a sense for what input
parameters are good as well so you learn
how the tool works and you can make a do
better things yeah and I think actually
building the computational creativity
system gives you some insight into that
a great example is this was built with a
data set that we created and released to
the public it was built off sample
libraries and it's it's the data set was
really biased to like trumpets and
synthesizers and stuff so it does it
sort of makes like it when I play a
piano through it it doesn't get it just
right and it kind of makes it sound more
like of a trumpet and so there's this
even in the training of a model there's
the creative inputs in terms of what is
the data that you want it to represent
you know and these types of things so
when you know let's talk about the the
visual arts you know there's got to be
an analogy to be made there oh yeah I
was actually thinking about what's
fascinating about love and Jesse's work
and I think it's that it takes place in
the sight of ambiguity like we we know
that when we train these sort of new
models of thinking to do things that we
already understand it's kind
boring but when it's to invent a new
recipe or if it's to invent a new sound
it becomes a lot more compelling and I
found the cat flute compelling I mean
well that's the thing and it's it's
ambiguous and it's novel but I think
there ways to create our own new
narratives using these tools like
instead of a cat and a flute I could
have a recording of my father's voice
and my favorite song the melody so
suddenly I could hybridize those things
and becomes a very meaningful way of
engaging with each other and like this
historical past and I think while
there's a lot of novelty like I like a
cat flute I would love to try cat food
but there's but there's so many
different ways we can use these core
components to to create beautiful new
interpretations that help us understand
these sort of aspects of our history is
a little bit is there a way that you
know these machines that that this is
kind of access that creativity has to
those ambiguous places is that something
that you're all working toward if we
develop these tools farther and even if
they start acting like like you can
treat it more like a garden you know
rather than painting like the individual
strokes on a canvas where you're you're
controlling it in the sense that you put
a certain amount of water on a plant you
know you choose what you plant and and
how much you know fertilizer to give it
or maybe a really you know compulsive
and you do like bonsai you know the
continued no cutting of all the leaves
and stuff but your control is more
high-level and part of the interesting
part is letting the system do whatever
it is that it's going to do and you
understand the system you go out each
day to your garden and you interact with
it as the as the things grow so I sort
of think of like AI Gardens in that same
sense that these these you know there's
various elements that you want control
over there's very elements that you
don't
these computational creativity
algorithms give you as a sense of safety
in a way so you can explore parts of the
creative space that you might be afraid
of a little bit because you have this
kind of algorithmic guarantee that it'll
work out it's a little bit like GPS
right it allows you to explore parts of
the physical world and you know you can
get home so that's another thing that I
really helps me when I use these
creative technologies pushes me a little
bit outside of my normal boxes and puts
me in different boxes but they're
they're kind of somewhere else and I
know it'll it'll work out I'm actually I
have a remark about that I feel the
exact opposite as I think about
collaborating with in a very
performative way this robotic arm
whether it's trained on my own style
which generation too is or it's or it's
just sort of mimicking my movements
there's a real randomness and sort of
sense of unpredictability to it and a
lack of understanding involved that is
it's kind of like exhilarating exciting
but it's not safe it doesn't feel safe
or comforting like staring into the void
well you know and even among humans
the phenomenon of apophenia where you
have two disparate unrelated bits of
stimulus the brain will try and make
some connections where maybe there was
no intention to begin with but a lot of
artists Peter make a lot of hay with
that and central to our kind of
creativity is taking known components
and constructing new things from them so
I can say to you for example you know
imagine an egg with wings that's flying
around the Statue of Liberty in holding
an ice-cream cone instead of a torch and
you can do that you know I could have
just said anything right and so these
mental operations seem to take place in
this aspect of our consciousness that is
this internal virtual reality that we
might call imagination so consciousness
has a sort of dual role telling us about
you know the world and our bodies in it
but also this internal virtual reality
and this is really central to what we do
and in order to do that
I think we have to have experience in
the real world with real things actually
you know in some of my work we've looked
at the mental operations using for
example rotating a physical object this
way or this way and then we could decode
if someone's imagining rotating it this
way or this way
probably because some similar brain
circuits are involved in actually
imagining in your internal virtual
reality what you learned in the real
world there's a program in France
actually at Sony France maybe Jess
you've heard this where they they fed
every Beatles song into this computer so
that the computer could learn how the
Beatles wrote songs and then they asked
the computer to generate its own Beatles
like songs and you know they had human
lyricists
[Music]
it says he tasted shining
[Music]
if you grew up on the Beatles it's just
like alright that's kind of cute if you
didn't grow up on the Beatles though III
don't know what your response to the
your response might be oh my god I've
never heard anything like this this is
brilliant you know so the idea you're
absolutely right I mean you know it's it
takes a conscious receptor to decide
whether something and and so this gets
us into the whole question of aesthetics
and taste whether something is in fact
creative or not whether something is
creative and the good sense is going to
be a human consciousness that says oh
that tastes good actually you know and
if my algorithm says well this this
should taste good and I actually know I
think it comes down to my conscious
experience and computers at least as
currently configured are not conscious
our creativity is very much rooted in
our own conscious experience of a world
and so based on my own conscious
experience of the world
i form mental models so I know what it
means for you to feel pain because I
felt pain and we're constantly modeling
things that are actually not in the
input I'm modeling what's going on in
your mind the abyss on what's going on
in my mind that's not visible and so a
lot of our creativity is rooted in our
mental models which are internal rooted
in our consciousness and so our voice of
a note of skepticism because in the
absence of mental models that are rooted
in conscious experience robots and AI
systems I think will the best approach
as if creativity but then I actually
think that's one braum in which the
arena of competitive games gets a lot of
traction in machine learning it's
because there is a set of constraints
there is a winner and a loser and styles
so in that way it creates a platform
around discussion that's a little bit
more stable than a conversation but
aesthetics do you feel like the realm of
competitive games and creating these
models that could be conscious and do
you think that's there
approacher or do you still think it's
created deep blue it could be Kasparov
but it was doing a brute-force search
through zillions of possibilities
whereas Kasparov would instantly see a
pattern so our brain is doing something
very different and it could beat him
just like an airplane can fly faster
than a bird but it's doing doing
something very different from a bird in
this case the human brain I want to take
just for fun the contrary point of view
on this because so a lot like you use
the Kasparov example right and there's
recently been these great successes of
this alphago program at beating the
world champions in go right and go and
the way that they do it is not through
brute force search right because that's
it's just computationally intractable
because the knick game goes is much more
complex but they do it through the
creation of these functions to represent
sort of intuition you know it's
represented like roughly how good do I
feel this move is and I can't tell you
exactly why I feel it's good but I have
you know this function that I've been
learning that says like if these pieces
are here and these pieces are here then
moving here is a good move and it's
because I've played a whole bunch of
games and I usually win when I when I
put my piece here when all those pieces
are in those places and similarly a lot
of the really cutting edge machine
learning and reinforcement learning
algorithms explicitly have modeling of
you know so there's some numbers present
that are saying like okay this is my
representation of the environment around
me this is my representation of what
this other actor is doing there's my
representation of what I am doing as an
actor in this in the system so the the
concept that like our creative critique
or you know analysis is somehow like
fundamentally human thing or requires
consciousness
I just find it to be a little bit of a
small definition because here you have
you can it's very easy to imagine agents
that can do things similar in nature to
what we might consider to be
consciousness but it's not human
consciousness it's just sort of a
broader definition
of how thing interacts with its
environment so you could have you know
computer critic in computer artists that
make art that's optimized for what a
computer likes but it's not necessarily
optimized for what we want you know and
it doesn't it's just just because it's a
possibility
doesn't mean I mean I think we're always
going to lend towards creating systems
that you know we enjoy interacting with
and that benefit us as a society and
benefit us in our own expression does it
seem like there are limits Beauty you
should weigh in on this as well - to
human creativity and is there a limit to
what artificial creativity might yeah so
you can figure out what's the maximum
speed a bird can fly through a forest
without crashing so right now the bird
is going pretty slow you can navigate
sufficiently quickly that you can avoid
all the obstacles and land on the tree
but if he tries to go too fast he'll
crash into the tree which I think
happens in the video and that's exactly
the fundamental speed limit of flight
through forests and there's a similar
fundamentals you'd limit for
communication and there's a and what
we've been trying to find and what we
seem to be finding is there's a
fundamental speed limits to creativity
as well there's this fundamental tension
you can't be too novel in a given domain
and you can't to be too too high quality
in a domain there's a tension between
the two so it's easy to be very novel
and low quality you just put random
stuff together it's very easy to be high
quality and low novelty you just look it
up in your favorite cookbook or wherever
it is but doing both simultaneously is
very difficult and that's where the
limit is and the larger the inspiration
set the the known stuff the harder it is
to be creative so if there's if there
are people in the audience who want to
be creative you should start a new field
where there's much more low hanging
fruit actually are there limits do you
think to human creativity as as lava
suggesting there are to computational
creativity I don't know I mean humans
have proven to be incredibly creative
both in the good sense of making you
know
airplanes for flight or for murder and I
think of our human imagination is the
greatest tool or and also the greatest
weapon we have because we can imagine
most amazing things and also the most
horrible things and like the Holocaust
there was an active imagination actually
and you know my hope is that these tools
will eventually foster human flourishing
cannot be used to you know also create
new ways of murdering people and I think
one question I would have for everybody
is what is the goal of all of this is it
just simply to make new artifacts or is
it you know I mean when I was a kid
there was the Jetsons and they had this
robot and you would say robot do the
dishes and you know it would do the
dishes but is it to make a general
purpose intelligence that would
effectively be a slave right and my my
guess is that in order to make a
general-purpose robot like the Jetsons
robot it would have to be conscious so
it would understand what I mean when I
say change the tires I have to have a
whole model of cars and everything but
if it's conscious then we have the
problem of slavery again because it
would suffer so consciousness implies
self-awareness awareness of self as
opposed to an other or others the having
of experience like pain like seeing
could a robot be conscious without
feeling pain I suppose I mean you know
there are actually humans who don't feel
pain and yet they see so yeah right
sociopaths
Jesse what about you know at your end I
think maybe another way of thinking
about it rather than just it's like it's
really nice to reflect it back on our
own human experience you know as we've
developed tools to better control
mechanical systems like we really began
to better understand how our bodies work
but what's amazing about these new
systems is they do a math that's not
human you know but it's similar in a way
that can help us provide introspection
in terms of what are what are my mental
processes you know what when I'm being
self-critical like what are the dynamics
of that how can I interrupt you know
that process and how does that affect my
creative output you know in these types
of things you can you can get
introspection in a quantitative way that
can help give you words because whenever
you talk I mean I live in the Bay Area
whenever I talk about this I just sound
like a hippie but like you know but it's
it's it's nice to have things that you
can point to to say like hey look this
is actual physical systems here this is
there's there's something here that cuts
common across human experience that we
can have a vocabulary to talk about I
think to that point - it's important to
ask why why we're having this
conversation now and I think part of
that I can flip that script a little bit
is we're generating all this data that's
being collected that's very very
difficult to wrap our brains around and
these mental models help us understand
the sort of complexity and the scale of
our own behavior as a collective world
and I think that's another goal
potentially of continuing to research
these new areas of cognition so let me
let me ask you to make one more trip
over to the table there and and you know
you gave us a demonstration before of
some of the elemental the basic gestures
that this machine that this this system
is capable of what if you try to do
something more complex okay yeah so
I think what I had here to show was sort
of more in the concept of creating tools
that actual musicians can use to explore
like so we had that novelty sound of the
cat flute right for example and so what
I've done here on my computer is to
create a we want to get this out in the
hands of artists and in musicians and to
close the feedback loop like because
creativity takes two to tango right you
know is there's the tool but the person
and so we want to get that feedback loop
closed so we created a plugin for this
popular software called Ableton Live
that if you've ever gone to see any
electronic music most likely it was made
just Ableton Live and so here what we
can do is instead of just interpolating
between two instruments we can create an
entire grid of instruments and allow a
musician to sort of take a sort of a
random walk take a walk through this
space and explore a whole variety of
sounds so what I can do is I can rather
than just play this with my hand I'll
just sort of play a clip here so right
now the instrument is like
an organ sound and you can see lead this
is the software going but you see this
we've created a manifold for people to
play on where we can actually just drag
through this space and see the evolution
of the sound as it goes between
different instruments and some of the
spots can also and we're like but you
know see the spots where it's in between
those different sounds and it creates a
whole bunch of different textures that
like alright that might be my that might
be the the you know start to my next
track you know or something like that
and gives you a ability to interact in
this space right that that you if you
were trying to design by hand to be able
to draw through those things it would be
very difficult to do mm-hmm
sort of one of those things and and Sue
Gwen
where do you see computational
creativity headed in in the visual arts
there's sort of analogous tools
available to you yeah definitely there's
a lot of like style transfer and this
sort of visual assists style transfer is
sort of the neural networks reading the
visual pixel data essentially of an
image a popular painting for instance
and then extracting that style like
starry night or what have you and then
transferring that into your next selfie
or a picture of your dog or something so
there's there's that yeah it's it's
compelling so I think there's that as a
very common approach to using these
systems and the visual arts now what I
get really excited about is ways in
which we can create new forms of
collaboration and through sort of
processes that we're training these
neural nets on what about the visual
arts as performative arts you know where
it's just I mean normally we we only see
the sausage we don't see the grinding
but it seems like with what you're doing
you want us to see some of the process
very much so I think for me the creative
process is much more important than the
outcome and that's what that's what
drawing as a collaboration that's that's
why it is drawing and not not dance or
not I think music performance is a
little bit more ambiguous but actually
being able to explore the drawing the
drawing mark in a way that isn't
representational could be a reflection
of consciousness or sort of exploratory
intentionality and doing that alongside
a article I hesitate to say artificial
intelligence but machine learning system
approaches approaches an understanding
of or at least could create a dataset
that could help us approach an
understanding of what the sort of
exploratory creative process well Jesse
you know the music music throughout
history really has had a kind of
ambivalent reaction to new technologies
you know oh my god digital music all the
musicians will be put out of work oh my
god pianos all the harpsichordist will
be put out of work and and yet we still
have real musicians we still have
harpsichordist even so you know the the
idea that there's room or a whole new
kind of generation of creative artists
in this field is it's kind of a new idea
but you know it's it seems like it
it has analogies to things that have
gone before right it's in some ways it's
very old idea that's what I was sort of
going that this is kind of just part of
a long coevolution that's existed
between technology and like music in
this case I think it really just takes a
generation that that really owns it you
know that they don't feel attached
particularly to the thing that came
before because they weren't alive when
that was
really happening so why should they feel
attached to it and some summer
traditionalists I'm I apologize right
but like I also like pushing it in new
directions you know and and so I think
that will always happen there always
would be people that find strength in
the continuity of of you know learning
that harpsichord from the 1600s you know
and those types of things right you
mentioned the word ownership and gets us
to the something I said before that I
want to come back to and that is agency
so love you helped create and and your
team helps to create this entity that
comes up with new fashion ideas new food
recipes new metal alloys who owns that
so the current understanding of us
trademark and copyright and patent laws
and it goes into the public domain
because there has to be a human inventor
to claim ownership machines don't have
property rights at least currently and
so that's the difficulty it creates this
perverse incentive for people to pretend
like they were very fundamentally
involved in the creative process but it
also raises the natural question how
should we think about property rights in
this area and and it's actually
important because who will fund the
computational creativity research if you
can't actually patent using those tools
eventually so there's no backwards flow
of incentives essentially so the nice
thing with say pencils is they're
considered research tools so it's not
the inventor of the pencil that gets
property rights on things that are
invented using pencils but the when you
do invent using a pencil you can claim
property rights on that right and so
similarly we need some incentives
perhaps a revision of this understanding
to encourage development of new
computational creativity technology I
think we'll also need wisdom and
handling these tools because you know
well any tool give you a two-edged sword
right a hammer can be used to murder
somebody or build a house and even an
atom bomb could deflect an asteroid
right
these tools are so powerful that they
can kind of take on a life of their own
and that I think is a danger and I think
there's an example of that in
everybody's pocket right these
cellphones are amazing right you have
all the information available in the
universe with Wikipedia right there but
it becomes very distracting and many
people know I was walking across the
Dartmouth green and this and the sky was
on fire with the red sun sun set and
everybody a hundred people were leaving
this and I almost wanted to say people
look at that you know but that I didn't
have the courage to do it um and I noted
that you know in my mind that 30 years
ago walking across that Dartmouth green
I would see 10 people holding hands and
I don't see that hardly anymore and
these devices meant to foster human
connectivity have in many ways
undermined it because people are more
distracted less attentive here instead
of talking to people like when I was a
kid and AI is very powerful but it runs
the same risk we have to own it we have
to become agentic ourselves and make
sure it serves our ends creative or
otherwise and that we don't become
slaves to it but if AI does reach a
point Jesse sue Gwen where it can
compose a piece of music create a
genuine work of visual art you know
something that moves us that the
genuinely passes the Turing test that
you know we know where it came from and
it it uplifts us anyway and you don't
care then then does that AI entity have
some sort of agency some sort of
ownership as opposed to the humans who
set it in motion maybe a generation
earlier I mean I know we're into William
Gibson territory now it's all good stuff
I I think like like grounding and what
you're saying about like cell phones and
stuff like it's really fun to think
about these these scenarios where you
you start thinking about personification
and
you know a constant evolution stuff but
the fact of the matter is for the
technology to ever reach that point will
have gone through so many transformative
you know things in our society they're
like there's lower hanging fruit than
that that will change everything and so
I always think you know and like there's
lots of groups at Google open a Aidid
mind that are really focused on more the
short term things of like you know like
how does this affect our society here
and now and if we ever reach that point
where the only way we'll ever do that is
if we figured out all the stuff that
comes before it because otherwise you
know it just won't happen but can I add
that in order to get to that point we'll
have to have deep mental models of what
it means to be a human being rooted in
what we have experience as being in
human beings right so for example you
know that scene in Liam is where Jean
Valjean has been in prison for 19 years
and he hates the system and he's angry
and he stays with his priest to it he
then steals the silverware of the priest
and police catch him and bring him in
and then the priests in an act of true
Christian grace says them release him he
he he didn't steal it I gave it to him
and here you forgot the platter and we
find that deeply moving and beautiful
because we can understand having hit
bottom and then by having hit bottom he
goes through a mental transformation and
he realizes I I'm not this I need to
become a new kind of person that can
only be understood by us because we have
human experience and I'm skeptical that
AI is going to be able to understand you
know redemption like that but maybe but
again if we get to that point they will
be humans or very close to us
so quite tough act to follow I think
part of how we even categorize what
makes us human is how we create our own
narratives like you explained sort of
this sort of profoundly human moment
through the narrative of limas I think
right now we're in the process of
creating narratives around machine
learning we're calling it artificial
intelligence we're calling it designed
intelligence
this is definitely an interesting
precursor to that question of agency we
form our own through creating narratives
and now we're able to co-create
narratives with these machines so I
think that's sort of the the path
forward well and and you know the the
arc of human history has been to
acknowledge agency for more and more
people you know agency was for many
generations restricted to a certain
gender and a certain group of people and
you know we we hope that that is a
continually expanding you know
definition of agency and whether it can
include things that are artificial I
guess that's a question that will be
answered down the road
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]